[Music]
let's talk about the Lakers for a second
they they've had a difficult season they
would have to yeah yes we do on the
contraction oblige you were you know
part owner of the Lakers and then you
get out the last time they went they
beat the Celtics in ten and then you get
out just as everything starts to fall
apart you are a genius
how did you know this was going to
happen how did you know you knew
something is magic can I go with you to
Vegas and hang out you know it's just
blowing my mind that a team with this
much town incredible amount of talent
yes you know when you think about all of
Famer Kobe Bryant Steve Nash would
probably be a Hall of Famer Dwight
Howard has a chance to do that as well
and you add Gasol in there this team is
better than the eighth place team in the
West and we've been up and down all
season long and I don't know we only
have I think 13 or 14 games left right
if they don't put it together they're
gonna go out in the first round and this
is shame because again the talent is
there
I don't know we've had a problem with
coach Dan Tony the system what the guys
are playing and then the guys themselves
so they're gonna have to correct it but
the exciting thing for the Lakers is
this they can beat anybody they have the
talent to do that will they get hot
right before the playoffs now you carry
that over into the play it's amazing
again all that talent and it's just
there's this thing it's very hard to
define where between the coach the team
and its team with each other it doesn't
matter they can all be hall-of-famer it
just has to gel or it's not going to
work you made a good point
if they do not come together as a team
the talent doesn't matter right and and
so they the Thunder the Spurs even the
Clippers they're their team their team
the Lakers have not gelled as a unit yet